i'm standing in a field with a cover
crop mix planted
and
this probably went in around the middle
of july it is now the 29th of august
so this was a wheat field that was
harvested so we're seeing
some
volunteer wheat coming up as it normally
does
and
the obvious thing is that buckwheat is
flowering
um that's going to make seeds so that's
obviously a problem
we have
radish
lots of radish
that is doing nicely
but many of them are really pale so it
is running out of nitrogen
so it's retrieving all the nitrogen but
a good
radish cover crop should have a better
nitrogen supply than this one does
we have a few odds and ends so we've got
a soybean coming up
we've got corn coming up
don't know what they're doing
sunflowers were part of the mix and here
and there
the sunflowers are doing
very well
one of the challenges with sunflowers of
course
is that they make
quite a thick stem
and that is going to be difficult to
manage
once they mature
so the question is what's the
decomposition
going to be in this how are they going
to manage
the buckwheat seeds
and
the radishes are going to be undersized
because they don't have enough nitrogen
but they've done a better job
managing the radishes
so
that one's only as big as my thumb so
far so it's got a ways to go and maybe a
challenge getting there
and oh look there we've got clover too
so by spring this may be primarily a
clover stand
and along with the winter wheat
so there's a look at a cover crop mix
that
looks okay now
good combination but
it's really a question whether it's
going to
do any job particularly well